alors toujours institut l'arctique
monsieur la salle
vous avez la parole oui je remercie
beaucoup monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
profite de cet article 25 qui évoque
aussi les moyens dans lesquels on peut
construire les problèmes d'urbanisme
pour signaler ce n'est certes pas la
première fois que quelqu'un de collègues
le fait ici à l'assemblée
mais puisque le loi macro permet de
visiter un petit peu l'ensemble des
problématiques de notre temps juin
profite volontiers pour dire combien un
certain nombre de lois et le
dispositions ne sont pas adaptés à de
vastes territoires de campagne et encore
moins à les territoires montagnards et
voyez vous monsieur le ministre
même la loi montagne que nous avions
élaboré il ya 30 ans face à brad ici
présent et a peut-être d'autres le
savent n'est même plus adapté elle non
plus elle a été dépassée par diverses
décisions sur des prises par la suite ce
qui est voyez vous très plus terrible
pour un vieux mer com - maire depuis
1977 qui voient ces maisons c'est un an
parfois les unes après les autres et
l'errance folle de l'oubli les envahir
lorsque ce n'est pas résidents
secondaires venus de bordeaux de
toulouse qui vient de temps en temps
mais qu il a de moins en moins d'argent
ils n'aiment pas beaucoup non plus mais
des fois ils achètent et ne fait pas
grand chose de sa résidence
donc
je suis rendu compte combien il était
difficile de passer au delà des
contraintes que nous avons dans tous les
domaines et des communes comme les
nôtres serait parfois sauver ainsi que
leur école par l'arrivée tout simplement
de trois au jeune couple nouveau mais il
n'y a pas la possibilité de les
accueillir parce qu'il n'y a pas la
possibilité de construire leur maison
nulle part tantôt parce qu'on est trop
proche de l'eau il est vrai que notre
scène anneaux qui s'appelle le lourdios
passe à 30 mètres de partout ensuite
c'est la paroi abrupte
ensuite c'est les zones avalanche un
site c'est tout le domaine qui risquent
d'être emportées par les eaux et
l'épopée rnc la zone sismique
enfin il ya beaucoup de contraintes qui
ne sommes pas tout
en fait vérifier mais comme on a pris
ses dispositions pour les grands centres
urbains
on est bien obligé de les appliquer
aussi sur des territoires comme les
nôtres et voyez vous il se produit ce
que mon père du temps l'oeil est
hébergée et me disait faut absolument
ton frère va s'occuper des bruits toi
essayer d'occuper un peu des hommes
tombent pays
fais attention si sanayeh bateau à paris
et dans les grandes villes
parce qu'un jour ils y seront malheureux
d'être trop nombreux
tandis que nous ne serons très
malheureux d'être trop peu nombreux
c'est un peu ce qui se passe c'est pour
ça je profite cette occasion monsieur le
ministre pour dire que des textes ne
sommes pas toujours adaptés et que
puisque nous visitons petit peu tout ça
il ya peut-être la possibilité de
trouver une adaptation à des situations
qui permettrait à l'ensemble de notre
pays de retrouver une forme d'habitat
harmonieuse